[Musica]
e quando ti rientra natale in circolo
che michael bublé esce dalla tomba e
tira fuori sti pezzi un po ci veda tutti
ragazzi video sono oggi siamo su un
videogioco tranquillo dove bisogna
prendere il tè no non è vero è una
stronzata siamo su dead rising 4 quella
non so perché ma era la musica del menu
e questi sono gli stronzi degli zombie
che devo far fuori con le mazze da
baseball bene a prescindere da questo
ragazzi in realtà non ho mai giocato sul
canale credo un dead rising anche se non
giocati un po ho fatto negli avvisi ma
sei scema cena voi voglio che vabbè
vabbè lasciamo perdere la sedia spero si
accomoda non mi pare di aver mai fatto
un dead rising per il canale per gli
altri li ho giocati più o meno è quindi
so di cosa si tratta niente ragazzi e
brevemente un gioco dove ci sono gli
zombie tanti zombie e io faccio le cose
nel caso vi steste chiedendo chi è la
mente malata che ha consegnato un
videogioco del genere bene
me lo chiedo anch'io prefiggo importante
questo guarda io spero che non mi diano
mai la patente nella vita che siamo
tutti e tutti quanti nella merda siano
anche voi e siete nella merda ragazzi
miei e valentino rossi può accompagnare
solo tua madre putrefatta che molto
probabilmente così io comunque ragazzi
sono in un centro commerciale vi dico
solo questo e tipo come quando facci
raduni nei centri commerciali a stessa
cosa varrà più o meno la quantità di
gente e la stessa la voglia di saltarmi
addosso o uguale purtroppo facciamo come
me quando faccio gli eventi nei centri
commerciali facciamo le cose fatte bene
adesso lo trovate sulla pagina del
centro commerciale è questo il tago sto
facendo la foto porca [ __ ] puoi farla
tu puoi fare tu il fotografo allora non
rompe riconosce un disturbatore la
rifacciamo tranquillo allora sorridete
pagate anche la vostra amica maria è che
viene al prossimo evento dato poi cambia
puoi cambiare la faccia da quanto è
bello scatto vita di tango tutti
minchia che border sede in dieci buca
una c'è chi porta gli ho dato sai se a
posto zio sturalavandini posso picchiare
basta costa musica che mi inquieta posso
picchiare la gente con ok è esattamente
quello che intendevo fare l'avvento a
vasta sono starbucks solo starbucks
fermi da starbucks devi caffè poi ti
picchiano degli zombie poi devi caf ed è
tutto come prima va bene che c'è bisogno
dell'arredamento per la casa salve
cos'è lancia di mi spieghi perché c'è
una lancia di pietra sul letto che
problemi ci aveva sto centro commerciale
così ecco la roba li caccia un cannone e
vabbè cos'è
ma cosa spara starò a ok ma sono cose
finte ma non è un cannone vero è finto
spara i giocattoli ma la vangol
mi fate testare solo questa per capire
come fai a puzzare di più sta roba
dovrebbe disinfettarsi spiega vinco se
quella roba lì me che state facendo
chi ha parlato
ma è vecchia di persone ma spiegatemi
nattino che sta succedendo
chi è che cosa sa su chi è che gli sta
facendo saltare in aria sono esseri
umani che combattono a non avevo capito
ma non sono miei amici cioè mi fanno del
male picchiare lo stesso forte sega che
siete esseri umani andate affanculo
perché sta gente guarda volevo dirlo io
vi spiegate chi diavolo e sta gente
perché ci sono esseri umani che
combattono altri esseri umani questo
invece un raduno ni pd fi per a tutti i
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo idoli
e happy meals anzi è di lady cifra
uguale anche l'amica c'è tutta la roba
lì è più anche quella la per l'offesa
fermi un attimo che devo capire qualche
va salve
scusate ma è che non so dove
parcheggiare scusate mi fa ecco infatti
togliti togliti togliti togliti aiuto
fatemi uscire di qua come si scenderà
sto coso
ok perfetto c'è chi cazzo quanti ne ho
fatti fuori così ok palla da spiaggia
sono contento che abbiano aggiornato
questo videogioco con delle armi
temibili rispetto
eccola la spara magliette non so che
cosa sia ma che è che cazzo se posso
chiedervi ragazzina roma ma nella vita
che cazzo serve una spara magliette
volete dirmi che nei negozi di
abbigliamento hanno le spara magliette
sul serio questa è una che sa di klein
questa è una zara queste scene a mandare
dicono
salve che quello arawak frate mi sa che
ti sei fatto malissimo peccato era
l'unico amico che potevo avere va beh
sono sfortunato nelle amicizie che vi
devo dire
come si trasformano tenta di essere mio
amico di abbracciarmi ma io non lo
voglio più
hai visto due is meglio che one ma forza
miseria porca vi cosa doveva frate non è
più il checco in faccia [ __ ]
prendessimo fino a stordire il nemico
più di premi perché è una piccozza
andiamo a trovare gli amanti su
minecraft devi avanti suo mai kraft
diamante io ho sbagliato strada a
prescindere non dovevo clienti quando va
bene sono dentro la david paich ciao
raga sega circolare bene ho già trovato
quello che mi serve
vi piace la sega ragazzi tutta per voi a
cosa serve la sa niente di combinarla e
vabbè questa roba qua spiega mi
inutilità ti prego
ho lanciato treseghe non ho fatto un
cazzo a nessuno lanciato una palla
gonfiabile non ci di tre ma le ragazze
arrivato il momento di farsi giustizia
da soli violo un'ala tenuto conto del
fatto che sono un essere umano è se cado
da 30 metri muoio va bene
la madonna ma potevo farli fuori così e
non sapevo calcinculo and air wing e lo
sto premendo a finissimo e vabbè la
madonna mi regalo delle magliette degli
stradivarius tutto per voi
porca [ __ ] lo faccio per voi lo faccio
di bim puzzolenti scolo faccio per volti
cazzone questo salva zio a vende del ben
del tu vendi il cibo nei centri
commerciali infestati fratello una
bottiglia d'acqua 600 dollari ma fa tra
piante al culo ma come venditore di
veicoli ma cosa minicar fa dei brand
audio c'è classe del nonno ciak
quanti soldi o 4 mila eur che posso
prendere speciale facciamo a segnarlo mi
spiegate il triciclo
ma voglio voglio solo ma prevedere che
cos'è sono curioso perché devo avere un
[ __ ] triciclo che ho pagato 2.000
dollari
c'erano delle cose fighissime l'aveva
affanculo
dimmi come posso essere letale con
questa roba spiegami motosega motosega
sono molto lusingato ammazzo a famiglia
una volta saga per te herat trita la
minchia credevo di non voler lasciare
più la motosega per il resto della mia
vita ma ho trovato un pesce spada
ragazze credo sia decisamente meglio
quando scusa gentile signore ma questo è
il libero della reggina santa se ne vado
e cortesemente a farsi [ __ ] fa
giocando con lo stronzo sbagliato
ragazze ci pensi tu zio a salve
non sapevo che l'associazione storica
dei [ __ ] fosse incinta
miguel di silius e la regina sandra è
incestuosa anche solo la metà di quanto
sembra è la donna dei miei sogni tua
madre era una marmotta e tuo padre
puzzava di deodorante spray questa frase
c'è la adesso in avanti tua madre
marmottan i video di con chi e tipo la
balestra che cento in mano me la mela
presti per favore grazie a dio la spada
nella roccia
o scassato la roccia va bene vabbè mica
neanche brock lesnar che placcaggio
fatto ragazzi ok ragazzi devo imporre la
mia supremazia su questo posto e devo
farlo facendo il più brutto possibile
gemme casa cresce royale cioè le gemme
di crash royale zio ho trovato ronaldo a
toti in a bag alberi che vedo che gli
interessa mi interessano delle gemme di
cles royale cliccate su questo link qua
sotto che vi lascio che vi trovate le
gemme gratis preme la infilo io tutte
nel culo salve buongiorno so che è una
giornata di merda devo fare una foto mi
scusi per fotografare qualcosa che
ricordi un kebab però non capito cosa
ricordo anche babbo ha mica non avevo
capito e o kebab sushi quali sono stati
canto io non so chi cazzo è ma che fai
vattene subito mio kebab noto kebab mio
kebab uomini di disastri che figata
e stato bellissimo ragazzo è stato un po
un casino ma figo balera che suoli con
cloro che l'episodio è stato è stato
fighissima vede tracing e bellissimo con
crolli avvisati ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto come al solito su mi è piaciuto
suo commento è un mi piace anche i vari
social che come noi via da tale
descrizione ci sono stati 16 b diavolo
fosse un video dei ragazzi